marketing for the now marketing for the
now marketing for the now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary
what do you think
welcome everybody to marketing for the
now
gary you had some pretty big news
dropped this week
i did lots of stuff going on in nft land
uh seems like big news for many projects
all the time so
uh fun stuff christy wow
thank you but um i'm fired up about
today
excellent well we've got one question
for today
you can see it right there how do you
create a sustain and entrepreneurial
culture
and we're lucky to have first up the
queen of clubhouse swan sit
swan has had an incredible career with
senior transformation roles with brands
like nike revlon estee lauder and she's
now advising her three and a half
million
followers on clubhouse in consulting
companies and leaders of tomorrow
welcome swan
hey guys thanks for having me
swan um let's just go right into the
question
uh because this go so fast they're only
10 minutes you know you know you've had
the luxury of
being in big organizations
right you've had the luxury especially
in your last year and a half of what
you've been able to build for your
personal brand with through the
explosion of clubhouse and the evolution
of that which brings you much closer
closer to the entrepreneurial spirit we
together me as an executive at
vaynermedia and you always had a great
relationship in the different companies
you were in we never got to go all the
way there and work together but you've
been around
entrepreneurs and around corporations
more than most which is why i thought
you were a tremendous person to start
this show with so in its lamest terms or
in its most complex undertone
how do how do leaders create
and sustain an entrepreneurial culture
i have this barbell approach because as
you know i worked at companies like nike
and estee lauder but i co-founded an
energy drink called annie with some
tick-tockers so i've got this barbell
approach and even being in corporate
digital transformation is all
entrepreneurship so one of the first
things i always think about is in
entrepreneurship people always say fail
fast and fail cheap
but if you fail in corporate you get
fired right so as a leader your job is
to take a hit for your team if you want
your people to fail you can't punish
them when they take those calculated
risks so it doesn't matter if you were
there or if you even knew about it when
your team gets a hit you take it for
them you take responsibility publicly
you coach privately because leadership's
not a reward it's a responsibility right
so i think that's the first step if you
really want people to innovate and push
you've got to make it safe for them to
do so
i think that's right talk to me about
your gut feeling on how many leaders in
corporate environments
are great at taking the bullet for their
team and then having a meeting and kind
of going into like okay i took that
bullet for you but like we [ __ ] this
up like you know
is it you know this is this one woman's
subjective call but are we you know i'm
gonna actually think of my number two
but like out of every ten executives in
these big companies
you know how many people really
you think go there
one or two
yeah and that's terrible right but to be
fair the corporate ladder is not
designed to reward that right
and i'm apathetic for taking the bullet
right it's like you have a mortgage you
have a family you take that book bullet
it might be the day where
your boss decides you're gone and so
it's not conducive to that
exactly so it has to go all the way to
the top if the ceo says we want
innovation it has to ladder all the way
down but you can't blame people for
playing the game that they're a part of
right and it's structured to not reward
that
yeah it's funny
i genuinely would argue that the 100
thing i focus on at vaynerx is to
eliminate fear because then it creates
the environment to give what we're
talking about a prayer talk to me about
the flip side you were a young hot start
executive coming up the ranks
you know it's probably likely that
there's more people listening and
watching that are in the structure of
having a boss or manager
what are some clever thoughts
some emotional intelligence
strategies
some nuances that one can do
in empowering their boss to do that for
them like what if you're the junior
person what can you do to maybe make a
little impact on that if it's not coming
from above you if anything
when you have a cool idea you have to do
the work of analyzing all facets of it
the idea might be cool but have you
thought of the downsides so sometimes i
find the bright eye bushy tail comes in
with a great idea and hasn't thought
through not only the execution and the
budget and the process needed but the
potential downsides so i found when i've
done this for team members have come to
me and laid out the plan not only is
this a great idea but here's all the pan
plan b plan c that will happen here's
the worst downside that we could do but
here's the big upside it's a calculated
risk at that point and far less scary so
that's huge in managing up right and so
then not only if you have an impact
within a company if you can also show
financial results but also show how you
develop leadership in the industry how
you become a case study how you do
things differently that's another halo
around that so you got to sell it in
just like any other idea
and then and then outside of because you
went right to the source the elimination
of fear i think it's i mean i'm i'll be
honest with the injury i'm sorry i want
to like shut down the rest of the
episode i actually think swan nailed it
but but that's heady stuff that's that's
you know that's the actual answer comma
give me some more micro answers what
what else have you seen
um observed firsthand or through
um observation of others that also lends
itself to entrepreneurial cultures
and and actually ask you something else
in our four minutes let me pick that
why do you think an entrepreneurial
culture matters
it lets people do their best work too
often in corporate when we have too
strong of a culture or two to define a
processes people fall in and you lose
the edges where innovation and drive
come from right people come in they
check in they phone it in and they go
home but the entrepreneurial culture and
it doesn't mean every single last person
has to have that but if you have say 30
of your company with that mindset you
start pushing the edges and with the
landscape changing every day i don't
care if you're not even e-commerce but
this last year has taught us that
digital is the future whether it's
external consumer internal to the
company and if you don't have at least
30 percent of your people with an
entrepreneurial mindset you just do the
same thing over and over so that's why
it's important and the thing about
entrepreneurship that i've seen now that
i'm in a baby startup is people are more
individual in a smaller company than
they are in big ones
and you have to foster that so one of
the things i've done and i've seen other
people since do since i started giving
this advice a few years ago is i manage
people individually based on their
personalities and strengths
for all my direct reports it is a lot
more work right of course we have
leadership styles you have one i have
one and that's a blanket one but when it
comes to direct reports i use
myers-briggs now we can debate which
framework works or it doesn't it doesn't
matter use a framework but you manage
the person the way they do their best
work and you get the best out of them
you get their loyalty you get that is
it's remarkably historically correct
right if you look at business for sports
it has been very obvious that any head
coach or any ceo she or he has always
always been more productive and
consistently productive
when they're reverse engineering the
human
yeah i and i think for me
you know
people that have that much empathy that
are capable of that what you have to
watch out for is a lack of candor that
was my
my evolution going into this next
chapter of my career is so
i feel so strong because i've been
building up my kind candor capability i
think when you're that empathetic that
you're actually willing to reverse
engineer the person
you can at times struggle with candor
it's a it's a it's a common trait
because
you're leading with optimism and
positivity and what's really fascinating
about lack of candor is it actually
leads back to fear because people don't
know where they sit and that's where we
started this final thoughts you got 60
seconds what else should people think
about with entrepreneurial uh cultures
whether it's an entrepreneurial venture
or a corporate venture
if you're able to do this understanding
that humans have different motivations
and incentives is really important so i
can't change a corporate incentive bonus
structure but i was able to do his car
about 10
and i let the employee choose how they
want to receive that last 10 which was
under my control right 50 corporate
maybe 30 40 team 10
what you want do you want more money do
you want more vacation days do you want
a mentoring relationship do you want
time for a side project that little 10
of choice
lets that person stand up and say you
see me i get rewarded in the way i want
and if that works god if you could roll
out across a company how would people be
seen and actually work to their
potential because it's what they're
interested in
swan thank you so much keep crushing
thank you good to see you
next up we've got lauren milan an
award-winning marketer entrepreneur
investor advisor and board member over
her 15-year career lauren has advised
and invested in over 40 startups that
have generated over a billion dollars in
revenue today
lauren is now the ceo of digital
undivided a leading non-profit that
leverages data programming and advocacy
to catalyze economic growth and create
pathways for black and latinx women
entrepreneurs welcome lauren
thank you for having me andrea hi gary
how are you
i'm well lauren but i don't know if you
know this the met gala was the other
night
i mean you're bringing
i i'm impressed
you are absolutely
i mean i'm like loving it here i feel
like i got to do a war wardrobe change
anyway lauren let's just get right into
it you know from your perspective you've
had a lot of you know different uh
angles and perspectives with the
startups you've seen you've seen
startups mature
you're a woman of the world so you know
that there's a lot going on in
corporations and i'm sure have plenty of
executive friends and things that nature
talk to me about
your perspective on this question how
does one create and more importantly
sustain
right because i think it's easy to
create when it's small
maybe from your startup investing what
does what is
the reality of the sustaining part once
the company starts getting big
you know i think it's a great question
but i am going to go back very quickly
to the outfit choice because i think
that we all have to show up because we
have to show up feeling confident and
feeling like we're on our a game right
so this is your brand this is my brand
um but this is also but this is also how
i have to show up in order to have that
excitement for the work that i do every
day because it's not easy work to do um
as i know you you know well right
there's the market
you know i'm sorry to interrupt it's it
it's such a great point that's why i
just want to jump in i'm sorry but to
your point we're both doing the same
thing even though it may show up to
everybody visually different i agree
with you that self-awareness game is
massive good for you
thank you um but i was inspired by being
able to come on and chat with you and uh
and andrea always brings her a game in
the fashion department so i figured yes
but when we're talking about you know
entrepreneurial spirit entrepreneurial
mindset i think what is so important is
to be unapologetically yourself in so
many ways i think that what often
crushes entrepreneurial spirit is
feeling as though the outside world is
going to reject our idea
call it silly won't see us um and so
half of the battle i do think is making
sure that you show up dressed in
whatever makes you feel like a rock star
so that regardless of the feedback that
you get your spirit your entrepreneurial
spirit your innovative spirit which
normally hopefully comes from deep
curiosity that nothing can deter you
from that because if you show up feeling
like i belong idea is great then you you
walk away from that room if you don't
get the response that you wanted saying
oh okay you just don't get it but it
doesn't feel like a personal attack on
who you are and i see so many people who
are bright like insanely bright and
insanely inquisitive you know begin to
shrink because they feel as though the
outside world doesn't appreciate the
perspective that they bring to the table
so i always say
go ahead i'm sorry no no just like
however you need to harness that harness
that feeling because i think that i've
seen so many people get super excited to
share something and they get one
rejection and it takes away every other
yes that they might have seen or heard
over over the years
lauren in a world where school
structure gives people validation every
90 days
in a world where people
are worried about how many followers
they have or comments i mean you're
talking i mean your entire manifesto
right there is a singular game of the
self-esteem
versus insecurity framework how does you
know a lot of people are listening you
drilled that i think about this a lot
because i talk about these things
how does one who didn't have the luxury
i have so many family members cousins
uncles
my family world the people i know the
best
best friends who didn't have the luxury
that i had which is i can do everything
you just said because my mother
instilled massive levels of
self-confidence in me
how does one go from
being a person that grew up in a
framework of insecurity now in their
adulthood in a professional environment
turn that gear on
you know that's a great one and i think
for me i'll answer it for myself
personally quickly and then i'll give
some something that i think can be
helpful to everyone who's tuning in
uh whenever people ask me this question
to lauren milan my answer is always
i went through that ugly duckling phase
i mean i had
this this stage of my childhood where i
had braids braces a size 9 and 10 shoe i
was super skinny i was everything but
cool butt hip um and i wanted to fit in
in so many ways and i think that you
know growing up um learning to kind of
reject what could be bullying or any of
these other things can very much turn
into our superpowers as adults i
actually just posted about this recently
it's like
whoa i mean the amount of kids that made
fun of me and called me one name after
the other you know was tough um whether
that was twiggy or even
you know being being called other names
from folks being questioned about my my
my blackness um those are all the things
that i went through my adolescence with
and i think if you can go through a
tough childhood and learn to pull those
experiences into how they can be
applicable in your adulthood
you garner strength from that you garner
confidence from that now not everyone
has that experience in their childhood
so for those people who who do not have
that reality because that was a tough
reality i don't really wish it on anyone
either but i do think that for those of
us that that want to kind of sit here
and go oh whoa me there are times where
we can look back and say but that made
me but surviving that means that as an
adult i can shrug other things off my
shoulders or other
biases or stereotypes is that be but but
i when i hear that talk to me about the
in you know so that's the external kid
world what was going on in your four
walls mom dad grandma grandpa older
sibling something was giving you the
strength to navigate through that and
then because i did the same thing turn
that into the ultimate i mean super
power like who was giving you that
foundation internally
absolutely my family um
particularly my mother
yes but in particular my mother and my
father who are both you know for for
their families first generation you know
major success story in their own right
my mom was a model first black model to
do a lot of big campaigns before there
was ever a diversity conversation my dad
one of the first blacks on wall street
back in the day so much so that he had
to start on the west coast out of san
francisco because he couldn't make it to
the real wall street until later right
so they broke barriers in their own ways
and i watched them do that
unapologetically my entire life but i
also um had parents that instilled in me
that i was going to often be the only in
the room and there are a lot of people i
think that you know looked at me and
said oh you know you grew up privileged
well maybe in part but it's also because
my parents made a conscious choice i was
an only child i got all of their
resources poured into me but the result
was also that i was often the only in
the room so even now that we're having
these diversity entrepreneurial
inclusion equity conversations i've
almost always been the only in the room
my entire life so i'm very comfortable
in situations and instances that i think
the outside world thinks or expects um
me or any other woman of color in in
this day and age to be uncomfortable in
and it's actually where i thrive instead
and so i think that throws a lot of
people for the okie doke if you will but
i think it's also part that
entrepreneurial spirit which is like i'm
here and
you might be surprised that i'm here but
the conversation the meeting will go on
so to synthesize the entrepreneurial
spirit from your standpoint
framework around
confidence within one's own reality is
found is the foundational stealing
concrete that one can build on top of
i think so i think so
and i also think that for those people
who don't have that experience in their
lives that you learn to do the things
that are scary to you and you begin to
almost compete with yourself i think so
much of the entrepreneurial spirit is
self-competition and self-reliance and
everyone has to do something different
to tap into that with my team at digital
undivided i stretch them every single
day and i can tell you you know the
first time i stretched them on a huge
project on a tight timeline they were
like we can't do it we can't do it we
can't do it i said we're going to remove
camp from the vocabulary and we're going
to learn to move things around and make
it happen
and yes it was a stressful week or two
but once we got past that all of a
sudden i look back and i have a
different team immediately i have an
incrementally different team that now
knows that they are capable of doing
what two weeks ago they thought they
couldn't do and not only do they think
they can do it they saw tangibly that
they could do it and then in addition to
that they saw that the outside world
valued and appreciated what we were able
to do and create together that kind of
you know confidence that kind of
self-awareness that comes from in my
opinion the accomplishment of
achievement in itself and so i think
there's a lot that people want to do
that we need a lot of people in life
that go i
have an idea but who let you try to
actually execute on it who's allowed you
to actually go implement it whether you
fail or succeed does it matter but do we
actually give people the ability the
chops the latitude and the platform to
even try to gain entrepreneurial spirit
or perspective and i think we have to
allow people to try and we also have to
allow people to fail because i think i
think it's when they fail you can also
work backwards to say okay but why did i
fail and in that moment
yeah it becomes the data point the
context when you're writing it might
feel huge but then you realize how you
can solve for that failure and often
when you go back and you look at how do
you create a solution around where you
failed it's actually a lot easier than
when you're in it in that moment
thinking oh my gosh this can't be
happening to me i think we have to allow
people
that opportunity to stretch and grow if
we want to foster an entrepreneurial
mindset and in closing i'll say the
entrepreneurial mindset is about being
able to work within highly matrixed
environments it's also about having a
certain level of autonomy to not just do
but to take something from start to
finish and we can't expect people to do
things that they don't get an
opportunity to try to do in the first
place i totally agree lauren thank you
so much for the knowledge thank you for
having me bye-bye thanks lauren
gary next we welcome tech founder and
venture capitalist alexis ohanian alexis
wrote bestseller without their
permission and co-founded reddit
in 2020 alexis founded 776 a new
software-enabled venture firm focused on
people culture and community
welcome alexis
thank you for having me what's up gary
i'm good brother you you get your slice
of pizza i see you coming out of the
clubs and uh
yeah dude
you'll you'll appreciate this i brought
a crypto punk to the met i'm the same
guy
the ceo said nfts would never be in the
met because there's no artistic value
it's entirely commercial
and
i it's
it's weird dude we see this play out
over and over and over again
where
institutions
really have a hard time dealing with
change especially when it's bottom up
especially when it's from the internet
and i don't know how you could be
sitting here in 2021 though and still
sleep on this and yet
most people
they're in their rem state they're so
asleep
it's why we've always had a connection
it's why we have good things happen for
us professionally because
much like your much better half on our
field like she does we do our thing and
likes sports it just plays out it's
regardless of what the establishments
and institutions say at the end of the
day
the
well-executed entrepreneurial executions
always win speaking of which i have a
really interesting question first thanks
for being on and i know a lot of people
are happy you're on
um
reddit right one of the most iconic
important uh
you know winners of the web 2 era one of
the most important foundational
uh structures in our society around
community which both you and i have been
incredibly passionate about for a long
time everyone what a lot of people don't
know
is that reddit once sold and went into a
big organization right
and so
you know i don't i actually don't know
how how how close you were to it when
the sale happened but i don't know okay
good
good
so tell me about this
you and your co-founder you know you
create this incredibly
strong entrepreneurial company you sell
it to an organization a bigger company
conde ness it needs to live within there
and then it comes out of there and is
now in its current state that people
know it
i don't think anybody can speak to this
better
there's three steps in there the first
and the third step are incredibly
entrepreneurially structured yeah and
the middle one is corporate structured
so when you hear that
what's the learning for everybody of
like what what happens
that's pro or con when you do lose an
entrepreneurial framework
i mean dude look i was
22 years old
uh i had been working on reddit for 18
months
and i'd struck up a conversation with a
guy i kind of asked who eventually was
like hey man you want to come work here
uh and
10 million dollars was a crazy amount of
value for
16 17 months worth of work
and at the time like like my mom had
gotten sick i had a lot of reasons
to want to get rid of that existential
dread and just make that phone call
literally the best phone call ever make
in my life was telling her
we sold it's done money's in the bank
like this was
life-changing money
more than my parents made their entire
working lives like for for a year and a
half of work it was crazy but
i did not have someone telling me
hey alexis if it's going this well
you should just raise funding at that
point we would raise 70 000
and i was so naive we didn't i didn't i
had never hired an employee before had
never thought through any of the obvious
stuff of business now
and you know i stayed a con and asked
for three a little over three years i
left in 2010
and
you know it was comfortable
and it was helpful certainly during the
recession and everything else to know
that i had a job and i didn't have to
worry about our revenue numbers that
much you didn't have to like it wasn't a
pressing need wasn't that existential
dread of being a founder ceo again
but when i came back in 2014
and it was you know
the company in almost i mean only a few
million dollars in revenue this is all
public
it was a tough tough place yeah
and and a lot of the work was then
re-educating brands i mean i spent most
of my time on planes right i mean i
remember coming to you
yeah like it's back
it's gonna take time but
we believe in this we have an amazing
team we're gonna turn this around and um
and that was where i really learned how
to be an entrepreneur um one of the
early hires there was uh caitlyn
holloway who was our first vp of people
and culture there she now
she's a founding partner of 776 and then
lizzie garvin who was chief of staff of
the firm and also with me here at 776.
and we got in the trenches and had to do
a lot of work to reset culture to grow
like literally double every year in head
count to rebuild the relationship with
brands get them to feel safe advertising
on the platform like the team did
amazing work and i saw firsthand what it
took
to grow a scale a rapid organization
rapidly growing organization
and i feel like that's where i really
look it's where i got on my gray hairs
and that's where your hair your ears
look really good this is the best
haircut i've seen you this is a real
legit haircut i got a real haircut
thanks my sister everyone thinks it's
for the met my sister's getting married
this weekend and i didn't want to
distract with the maine
so samson
knowing you grew up in that same year as
i did a lot of our friends companies got
real you know different but they did
raise capital they got big yeah kevin
kevin did it right i'm friends with
kevin rose now kevin you're right you're
raising money
yeah
talk to me about
what you've seen from the outside of a
lot of our friends
companies that went from three four
people in a y combinator a small company
to 5 000
employees in all your travels with all
these people back to the theme of the
show where do where do those founders
struggle where
what's the common thing where they go
you know they always say this thing man
we've lost some of our speed our
entrepreneur they wake up i mean vayner
i'm [ __ ] you know me i'm really in my
[ __ ] and like vayner at 1800 vaynerx at
18 1500 wherever we are 1800 whatever
the number is right now can't be what it
was when it was me and aj in a
conference room right
what what what do you see as the themes
or the anecdotes to when they feel
they've lost their entrepreneurial
spirit
you know
so something that stuck with me that
caitlyn told me early in the red this is
now like 2015. she said look
this company is going to double every
year in headcount and every year that it
doubles the culture totally changes
so be prepared for a totally new company
and need to do a reset in order to
maintain the stuff that got you there in
the first place yeah and so part of it
is as a ceo
trying your best to stay on top of and
this comes down to values this sounds
like cheesy stuff that my 21 year old
self would roll my eyes at
but values are the things that if you if
you do them intentionally and you you
really develop a culture around them
they help the thousandth person
make a decision as if the founder were
in the room and it's never going to be
more good but it's the best [ __ ]
thing you can do it's [ __ ] religion
yeah if you want everybody to understand
that speed or kindness or break things
or whatever you put on the like if you
pound that into the soul
scale i agree
and and and then
it is hard right as organizations grow
you just invariably get bureaucracy and
all this other stuff but
i think where software is going to
redefine organizations going forward now
is is a byproduct of covid and sort of
decentralized work okay we have a chance
i'm working with founders now
who
they're starting their company in the
last year they've started it as a remote
first company because of code and even
as they flex back into office
their dna is around asynchronous work
it's around sort of execution focused
work because there's no chance to have
gossip around the water cooler if the
org started
in a digital first way well the gossip
the gossip can go to slack
for sure but the
there is a
the the idle culture of being in an
office doesn't exist now that has the
upside the upside is it's a you get a
chance to be more relentlessly focused
on execution the downside is you don't
have as much of that natural kind of
culture
yeah
and so now the work is how do we build i
think this new generation of company is
now going to look for more creative ways
to create that that sort of that culture
the the the serendipity
of the office even as they come back now
that their dna is formed in
in execution right async like why bother
having a meeting if i can just record a
loom video and you can watch me at 2x
speed
whenever you [ __ ] want
i can't i think it's like that shift we
just have to do new work now to build
culture internally
i hate that we've run out of time i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna already run out
of time yeah these are faster i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna hit you up
and we're gonna do a real podcast you
and i we need to but i have to ask you
something is that the first edition
first appearance of deadpool
is that a new mutants comic over there
you are very very very very good hold on
you mean this
yeah dude i've got that's hilarious i've
got like five of those in my vault
we need to talk comics i love you buddy
thank you soon
thank you alexis
and thank you gary
this is the awesome love you
love you too next up we welcome shelly
haas cmo of ulta beauty
sh prior to basketball hi shelly how are
you how are you we've got ryan harwood
that's going to be joining us today too
just a little bit more about shelley
though first prior to her role as
joining
as cmo of ulta beauty shelley spent her
career in consumer packaged goods uh
with companies including procter gamble
and pepsico
three things that shelley would bring
with her on a desert island spf lotion
smokehouse almonds and of course lip
gloss
today shelley will be joined by our very
own ryan harwood ceo of gallery media
group welcome to you both
thanks andrea hey ryan hey shelly how's
it going mario
good incredible introduction but more
importantly an incredible human so it's
so good to see you
really good to see you too thanks for
having me
yeah so being the cmo of the largest
beauty retailer in the u.s with 1300
stores across 50 states it's no easy
feat yet you're delivering record
results right now with q2 sales of
almost 2 billion which is crazy
tell me a little bit about your mantra
what what you what got you here won't
get you there and how your
entrepreneurial mindset has led to your
success at ulta
i think if you asked any of the leaders
on my team what my
what my biggest go-to mantra is they'd
say what got you here won't get you
there it started when i when i started
with the company almost seven years ago
i i came in to change things i mean
that's why i was hired so i was like
okay how am i going to do this because
it was pretty clear early on that people
were really comfortable in their success
because the the the company was already
doing really well
um but things were going to change and
so i just i latched on to that early on
you know so it's that old book that was
written about career and what got you
here won't get you there in your career
but i just thought it was really good
for us to latch on to that as a as a
mantra for the team
and and it's been a mantra ever since
and i'm just i'm so glad because we've
created now a culture of people that
think that way you know they're always
looking toward the future always
thinking around the corner no matter you
know if we deliver a two billion dollar
quarter that's way above expectations it
doesn't matter
what got you here won't get you there so
so that's been really important because
you know as i was really
growing the team and really pushing
people and bringing in new great talent
and kind of you know really reshaping
what this looked like that that was
really the cornerstone of you know now
how we think
absolutely you know it's funny if you
create an atmosphere and culture that
eliminates fear
and encourages ideas from everywhere
because employees aren't fearful to
contribute freely then it fosters that
entrepreneurial spirit totally it's that
idea of like just go for it like
everybody here should want to go for it
and if you're just hanging out it's
probably not going to be it's not going
to be the place for you so yeah it's
just it's just a different mindset all
about the mindset
so you know when you are looking to hire
to get people with that mindset or at
least people you can mold into that
mindset are there are there any unique
qualities you look for or or screen
against specifically
i mean the first one you know alexis
just touched on this and he kind of said
like it might sound cheesy because if
you know you you said this to your 21
year old self they'd be like oh my god
but values is like the first thing
because i i think that you shouldn't
hire people just like you except in the
area of values because the idea of
having like people who are really
authentic who care about team who care
about culture who care about the values
of the company and it's going to be like
a number one priority it that's like
has to be their deal breaker if it's not
there if you do and a lot of that is a
gut feel i mean you can try to like
scream for that and ask questions for
that but it's tough you you get a gut
feel about people and you know you said
good human being i mean you got it like
good human beings that are like no drama
like has to be
then on top of that like the idea of
being innovative and creative
but more than that kind of like if
you're a change agent it's about the how
you know especially when it comes to
doing it in a values-based way and
really getting an understanding for how
those people wire i always call it like
wire and organization because it's tough
to wire an organization especially when
you're doing new stuff
so the ability to do that um and create
that change is is what i look for in
leaders when i bring them in or when i
grow them up um throughout our marketing
organization
totally
i have a fun one here how would you
handle integrating
a former marketer into your team if they
had been frozen in time for 50 years and
now they're coming back into society and
they're joining your team but they were
a former marketer how would you
integrate them
first of all i feel like this is a good
seed of an idea for a netflix show if
you feel like that like i feel like that
could be a really a really interesting
thing i don't know i i think it you know
you have to be on the forefront of
culture and so if you're gone for 50
years holy crap
so
we just talked about reddit
i would say get get on every social
media platform and devour it get in get
into reddit get into tic tac like you
got to just devour everything that's
going on there and talk to kids yeah you
know i mean talk to the teenagers talk
to the 20-somethings you know i have two
of them uh who are 21 and 19 and they're
always like mom you need to do this you
need to do that
and they they just they just know so you
know if you're frozen in time come back
and talk to kids
totally you know what's funny when i was
growing up it used to be the older
people used to influence change in
decisions you looked up to people that
were older than you i feel like now
in this generation
the younger people influence the older
people more than it used to be
100 it's like reverse mentoring i mean i
have a lot of the experience and wisdom
and ability to you know lead the
organization but i don't have all that
so we got we got to bring those two
pieces together to make to make the
magic
how do you think consumers attitudes
towards beauty and makeup have changed
during the pandemic
this has been a super interesting time
in beauty because beauty is really
emotional and really um meaningful
but over the last year and a half it's
become way more of that you know the
idea of self-care and and that tie to
beauty
where people were
at home and feeling lost and
anxious
um the self-care routines and not just
with skin care but that was a big part
of it but even with makeup with hair
care like that whole self-care thing
just accelerated even more and so that's
a really interesting space for us you
know now now people are um
coming out of the pandemic ish
and feeling like they want to feel new
again so then they're looking at beauty
you know in a different way it has a
different meaning now that people are
trying to get to like this balance of
fomo and what we call fogo fear of going
out fear of missing out fear of going
out fine line
so you know it's really fun to see
people engaging in new ways and getting
excited about beauty in new ways because
of what's happened over the last year
and a half totally pretty wild
yeah i mean i remember you
when we were having a conversation off
the cuff you were telling me a little
bit about ulta's c beautiful today
platform
that you launched like three weeks
within lockdown
how did both speed and flexibility and
and listening to your consumer consumers
contribute to that campaign's success
yeah i mean that goes back to the
entrepreneurial mindset 100 i mean first
of all i look back and i'm like
thank god we worked so hard to get our a
team together both uh in and our ulta
beauty team as well as on our agency
side because if we wouldn't have had
that i don't know the whole thing
probably would have imploded but because
we had that and because we had done so
much work on our brand purpose platform
we're a purpose-driven brand
and the idea of being able to use the
power of beauty to bring out the
possibilities in every person
is our true north and that gave us the
ability then to say okay we hadn't
planned a new campaign until september
but like stuff's going down right now
and people need you know something to
lift them up and this idea that we could
really be the light in people's you know
darkness and anxiety led us to the idea
that you know beauty's all around us and
we were gonna see beautiful today and do
it together so we just busted a move
within three weeks
and um used you know ugc because
we can shoot anything and that was
awesome because it just led to a
completely different mindset we used
that platform throughout the year and
put out new content all year long and we
did it in different ways whether it was
ugc or remote shoots it just you know i
always say like don't forget the lessons
of 2020 because it taught us a lot about
being entrepreneurial and breaking
things like
you can move that fast you don't need a
brief like all the things that you and i
have talked about before speed is the
game speed of ideation speed of
execution it is the game these days
um
i saw all the news about ulta beauty at
target that partnership it was super
cool to see that i'm so curious how did
that come to be
how did that partnership allow all to be
more accessible to consumers strengthen
the brand all of it yeah it's a it's i
just i'm so excited about the
partnership we just launched a few weeks
ago we have 100 stores 100 store in
stores now it really started from the
idea that we're an innovative company
target is an innovative company we are
also two brands that have a lot in
common when it comes to the consumer and
when it comes to the ethos of the brands
and so the idea of bringing the best of
target omni omni-channel retail 30
million people through the doors every
week target runs and the beauty prowess
and expertise and perception of all the
beauty together to make this like retail
powerhouse is really where it where it
started and i just like speaking of
speed i mean this is like we just we
just announced this last i think it was
november and and we just launched like a
brand new retail environment
uh new.com experience like breaking the
paradigm i mean we we really moved
and i'm just i'm really proud of the
experience that we're creating in the
store it's very ulta beauty but it's
also very target it's really intimate
cool like i'm just so excited about what
we have in front of us
andre can i do a quick speed round with
with shelly really quickly do i we're
already a minute over you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna have a show
just with you guys okay
we have so much to talk about i know
it's so true
all right thank you guys enough awesome
thank you good to see you
our next host is zach nadler ceo of
vayner speakers
and we're so excited to have haley rosen
the ceo of just women's sports join us
coming from a professional career in
soccer haley has now changed the game
for women's sports coverage just women's
sports is a digital first consumer media
platform providing 7 million passionate
fans with in-depth coverage of women's
sports and it's been growing 300
year over year
welcome to you both
awesome thanks andrea haley it's great
to see you thanks for joining us today
yeah thanks for having me and thanks for
that intro that was great
well since ryan cut our time a little
short i'm going to try and uh jump right
in um but before we go into that tell me
before we dive into the theme just give
us a quick 30 seconds on just women's
sports yeah just women sports is exactly
what the name says we covered joss
women's sports and um it's kind of
touched on in the intro but the whole
idea is you know four percent of sports
coverage is dedicated to women's sports
but that doesn't match what's happening
in the space attendance is uh viewership
is up general interest is up
participation is up and so there's this
huge sort of unmet opportunity to really
cover women's sports and that's what
we're doing that's incredible you guys
are killing it right now and obviously
andrea mentioned it your background you
played d1 soccer at stanford you're a
professional soccer player
with today's theme around culture i'm
curious you know what similarities have
you seen from you know working in a team
as a culture and then creating a company
and building the culture around that
yeah i think this is really an area
where sports and
you know work really really overlap and
i think there's
two things that i think are just hold
true for both one is you know knowing
you know what you're doing knowing your
mission knowing your purpose when you're
on a team usually you know you want to
win the league you want to win the
national championship right the goals
are really really clear so making the
goals really really clear for the
company where you're heading where you
want to go and in what time frame i
think that is just really critical and
i've seen that really drive culture both
on a team and in the workforce and then
second is you know empathy when you're
on a team you can't help but just
empathize and feel for your teammates
right like you're on the line doing
fitness and someone's struggling like
you're giving them a push or maybe
someone's pushing you or you know you're
shouting in the locker room like you
bond and you get to know these people
and who they are inside and out and i
think that does matter and that's you
know it's tough as you scale but i think
just generally leading with empathy and
you know treating everyone as people
that have their own you know hopes and
dreams and needs but want to function as
a team like that for me like is just
very clear as day just
in sports and in work
that's great well you're certainly
speaking our language empathy is in our
dna here at all the vayner companies
and another thing that we have in common
i think is the passion that comes from
our founder right gary is very
passionate about the work that we do and
i think you're super passionate about
women's sports and i'm curious in the
world of culture how do you kind of
build a culture around that passion so
that all your employees the entire
company feels that same way
you know zach i this is like a really
good question um
i don't know but it's the only thing
that we've done because i like i love it
like my heart is on my sleeve we are
fighting for this day in and day out we
believe in the mission with every fiber
of our being and i think that we attract
people that feel that too that they they
see it on our instagram or they see it
in our podcast or hear it in our podcast
they see it in the way we talk like they
they get it they feel that thing that
we're feeling too and it just has built
from there and i think you know as we
scale and as we grow like we want to
keep attracting those people and we want
to sign them up to be on our team and
keep growing that passion because you
know for us like we're
you know we're
15 people right now and we want to
compete with media organizations that
are hundreds of people right and to do
that we're gonna have to have heart and
hustle and passion and i think we have
that in spades and for us it's just to
keep pushing on that that's awesome and
i mean this kind of goes alexis touched
on us a little bit about companies today
you know being together all virtually
you started this company during the
pandemic so your team of 15 people
you're not spending every day together
and frankly you guys don't spend that
much time together in person so how do
you navigate creating this this culture
that you've built well everyone is all
over the country
yeah it's a really good question i mean
we've only known this way and i think
just for us like this sounds maybe
cheesy but setting up like really good
operational processes of you know having
certain count uh meetings on the
calendar like from literally just you
know weekly one-on-ones or monthly
one-on-one just really being diligent
around
when do we need to communicate when do
we need to communicate live when you
know when does something need to come
off of slack or off of email it needs to
be a phone call um you know and we're
learning as we go but i think for us
it's like the north star is just empathy
and teamwork and so you know something
we also say is assume positive intent so
if you're going back and forth on slack
and something's getting crazy it's like
take a breath pick up the phone give
that person a call because you know
we're all on the same team so i think
you know it's something we're figuring
out but i think
getting our operational processes tight
and finding times for virtual happy
hours as
as much as no one wants to log on to
zoom at 5 pm like it does matter and it
makes a difference and you know we'll
keep learning and growing as we go
i love that and i think like the
teamwork you've built like your empathy
is right there you said you're wearing
it on your sleeve like it's 100 in the
way that you built this whole thing have
there been challenges that you've seen
around that because i love the idea of
positive intent but obviously things can
go wrong so there been things that you
know you would have done differently or
things that you look forward to doing
differently in the future
yes
of course
i love it
yeah i mean we've made a ton of mistakes
like something we also say and i'm
realizing how many things we say now
that we're having this conversation but
is you know we don't have to get it
right the first time but we have to be
the fastest to learn so like we can make
mistakes but we need to learn quickly
and so we have made so many mistakes
like internally externally you know big
decisions little decisions like
probably made two mistakes today like
you know that's part of it but for us
it's just about learning quickly and i
think you know to go back to sports like
something that people say is you know
next one or next touch like there was a
like a thing in soccer at least when you
would turn over the ball be like go get
it back go make the next one good and i
feel like that's really kind of a
culture that i want to bring into you
know just women's sports of like all
right maybe that wasn't the right call
but what did we learn and how do we make
the next one right and like we just keep
pushing on that i mean just jumping
right off of that you guys have already
built this this company you're 15 people
i know you're growing and you're
competing with behemoths so as you guys
continue to grow how do you actually
plan to keep that culture sustained
because obviously you know the more
stretched you get the tougher it gets so
do you have any plans or ideas around
how you'll continue to do that
i think
having an incredibly clear mission
matters so much there's no if ands or
buts around our mission and where we're
going in this vision 100 i think every
single person could recite the things i
say over and over and over but i think
we're all bought in and we get it and i
think that really really matters and
then i think also just you know from the
top down from the bottom up i keep
coming back to empathy like i just think
i
and listen i'm early in these days but
from everything i've seen it really for
us is it's mission and empathy like a
hundred percent treat people like
teammates care about each other work
hard you know be accountable to one
another and know where you're going we
know where we're going no doubt and like
we just got to push to get there
that's incredible well you mentioned
speed you mentioned where you're going
and i'm excited to see you guys go there
um i appreciate you jumping on with us
here thanks for your time zach thank you
so much for having me this was awesome
thank you haley and zach you guys are
awesome amazing
our next host is the one and only wanda
pogue vaynermedia's chief strategy
officer and we welcome mark hans ricker
richer
the svp chief marketing and innovation
officer at moen leading the smart water
revolution for over five years
previously mark hans was harley
davidson's first ever cmo and a fun fact
mark hans taught pygmies in the congo
how to sing
welcome to you both
thank you thank you andrea and hello
mark hans it's so good i want to see you
again
i've seen you i i think with that little
thing um that little bit of information
that andrea just shared i almost want to
go off script completely and have you
talk about that but i'll try and save
everyone
um we had the opportunity to meet
briefly and and you know had a great
chat and i think you shed such great
light on the differences between
you know being on entrepreneur and
entrepreneurialism and
entrepreneurialism i would love to be
able to start there you know and just um
what is the difference what is
intrapreneurialism
yeah this is a huge passion point for me
and and i think it is an important
distinction because people fall in love
with the idea of entrepreneurialism and
they i think sometimes mis
misunderstand what what you're talking
about they fall in love with companies
that are inherently entrepreneurial
which are very rare uh startups or in
creative industries uh that that are
like that and
much more often the opportunity is
within a company that's already well
established they're they're a legacy
company they've been around for for
decades they've got well-established
processes and all kinds of things and
people that have been hired to protect
those
things that have built been built up and
frankly have built the success of the
company up to that point
so when you're an entrepreneur you have
to work within a legacy company to
figure out how to make
transformational change
while also running the play of the of
the company and the success uh drivers
that got him to that point so so people
have this dream this fantasy of i'm
going to be in this entrepreneurial
culture and it's just going to be wild
and crazy we're just going to do
whatever we want and it's just going to
grow and it's going to be great and and
that is actually a very rare experience
the much more
the much more likely experience is to be
in a larger company where you're trying
to do that same thing but within a
larger um
cultural construct that is harder to
work within yeah so tell me a little bit
about that because i think um you know
some people may say well it's actually
easier you have the support of an
already established organization but i'm
sure it comes with a lot of challenges
as well so what are some of the
challenges in
you know perfect example a moen a
company 65 years old with over 3 500
employees how do you inject you know the
culture
um
of entrepreneurialism yeah well this has
been something i've just been kind of
involved with my whole career um at
general motors at harley and now at moen
and
um
they're you know general motors 100
years harley 115 years moen is actually
80 years
and uh and all of them have had great
successes and yet also challenges and
opportunities for change and the the
issue is really
everybody really likes change the idea
of it but when it comes down to what
does that really mean and what does that
mean to me if i was hired you know 10
years prior and i'm my responsibility is
not to screw anything up and that's
basically what i've been told to do
that's what my job description says is
run the play
please try not to lose
change can be scary and it's not because
anyone's dumb or anything it's just that
this is what they've been incentivized
to do
so that's actually the biggest challenge
is the mindset shift uh not not because
someone's bad or good but just because
they've been incentivized to to run
run a play a certain way and they've
gotten used to that and been rewarded
for that now you're asking to do
something different
and the truth of the matter is and
there's been a decent amount of research
on this is that within a corporate
culture only about 15 percent of the
people are actually entrepreneurs people
that have the the you know the sort of
will to to make more transformational
change and the other 85 percent are not
but again it's not about good or bad
it's about you know how do you change
the focus how do you change the
incentives how do you how do you inspire
and also um enable and not just inspire
but really enable a culture to to
liberate more of the power of the 15
not because of the people but because of
what that will do ultimately for the
business
yeah you know in the very beginning um
gary and swan spoke about you know
creating a safe environment you know do
you think that that's important in order
to be able to you know kind of foster
the spirit you know of innovating and
maybe deviating from what's been done in
the past how important is creating you
know that that level of safety among the
employees and ensuring people feel safe
and then how are you doing that yeah
this is kind of the go-to thing now
because google came out with their study
and talked about psychological safety
and you know i got to say there's a
little bit more to it than that and
again it's it's easier in startup
companies it's easier when you have a
leader like gary you can just declare
everything from on high and everybody
has to act that way
uh when you're starting an organization
that you're not running
uh
and you are surrounded by 85 percent of
the people who are not going to get
psychologically safe it's going to take
a lot longer for them to get
psychologically safe the ability for you
to actually change is very very small if
that's what you're waiting for
um it is just it's just it's not going
to happen because it's it's just too big
of a company to try to get everybody on
that same plane of understanding and
feeling that level of safety to make
that kind of change
if you're truly pushing bigger change
you know nominal changes yeah you can do
that and then if you do get a whole team
that's feeling safe and executing well
they're surrounded by a bunch of other
teams that may not be on the same plane
and you have to work with them
in a big company you've got to work with
a lot of different people and you have
to bring them along and and you have to
respect their point of view which might
be hey i don't want to do that or i
don't want to go that fast or i don't
want to make that change and so you have
to respect understand and then
find a way to bring them along in a way
that actually might never make them
totally psychologically safe
but they have to they have to be part of
enabling the change or else you're never
going to get to the change so it can't
be that that simplistic in a larger
organization
um our agility and you know everybody
talks about agility nimbleness being
able to you know decide fast fail fast
you know how much of a struggle is that
like in a larger corporation and are
there any
pieces of advice you know for still
being able to move fast which is
critical but um doing it in a way that
allows you the time to bring people
along as you were saying or to you know
just have due diligence yeah i think
people are okay with failing fast as
long as they know it's for the it's for
the bigger purpose that we're that we're
seeking
if you're just trying stuff breaking
stuff trying to move fast agile that way
but no one really understands why
there's glass all over the floor and
what what it was for
um then it becomes more of a feeling of
why did you do that
why'd you break that stuff
so i think it really starts not so much
i mean agile has to be in service to
something bigger that people can
understand the clarity of focus
the the big hairy audacious goal to use
an older term um if people understand
what they're going for then it's a lot
easier to be agile and move and and then
failure isn't so scary because you feel
like it's failure in service to
something that
everybody's signed up for um if if it's
really just moving around acting fast
breaking things for the sake of you know
looking fast or being fast uh without
that larger purpose objective then then
it probably won't last very long
right
um which makes total sense in terms of
um concrete examples you know since
you've been at moen that you might be
able to share in in ways different ways
that you've been able to innovate you
know whether it's um new partnerships
new acquisitions you know
and any kind of examples that you can
give of how you've recently have done it
because i think sometimes people think
innovation only means you know creating
something new are there different ways
that you've been innovating at moment
uh well mullin has a lot of great people
at it and a lot of really smart creative
people the best example i can give you
is actually the most recent one which we
literally just launched this week so i i
know i'm not supposed to be on here
pimping stuff but i'm going to kind of
do it
to your question
um we had a team inside of our company
that developed a great iai tool and the
ai tool was
built to recognize faucets a lot of
times people call into their service
center and they don't really know
what model of faucet they have they may
have bought the house and not the actual
faucet themselves they adopted the
faucet when they got in there and
they're looking for help but we can't
really help them very well because we
don't know what you know what they're
talking about
because there's no easily identifiable
marks on it so this
wonderful gentleman developed this
and some other folks around and
developed this tool ai faucet recognizer
basically which is harder to do than
you'd think
and uh because there's always a lot of
clutter around faucets and you know it's
not easy for ai to recognize things that
that that well
so once the final uh you know sort of
hone the tool we said well this is a
wonderful opportunity to go direct to
our consumers and let them know that
this is available so that they can have
a direct relationship with us and also
of course highlight the innovative tool
that we've developed internally and
you know focus on on the great faucets
that we have so we we built a great new
commercial it just came out this week
and um and it basically
features the faucet identifier the moan
identifier which is now enabling people
to take their phones and take pictures
of their faucets and send them directly
to us and then we can serve them better
so it's technology and innovation in
service of a brand ideal and in direct
service of our consumers which has not
been done before in our industry frankly
i don't think it's been done in many
industries um so it was not a let's do
ai for the sake of ai it's let's do ai
in a way that's really meaningful to our
brand identity and a direct relationship
with our consumer and so we're very
excited about it and have already had
more than a thousand people reach out
with pictures of their faucets to us in
just the last couple years it's been
pretty cool to see that's amazing and um
very consumer-centric and i think that's
the heart
at the heart of everything um
last question um how do
you prevent failure you know from
hindering innovation and entrepreneur
that entrepreneurial spirit for the
future
yeah it's it's it's just not it's not
being too heavy about it and not even
calling it failure it's it's just
something else we learned um great
phrase that i i love is only make new
mistakes
and and so you know all right we made a
mistake book it let's learn from that
let's not repeat the mistake we learned
it let's not relearn it that would be
bad but let's go make some new ones uh
and it's okay so
um you know only make new mistakes is a
real mantra we've talked a lot about
mantras on this on this
and that's one for me that always sticks
uh sticks with me is um
you know mistakes are okay as long as
you learn from them
love that love that i think those are
great words to you know to be able to
part on
thank you so much mark hans thanks wanda
thanks to you both
thank you
thank you wanda
and thanks everybody for joining the
marketing for the now and we're hoping
you'll join us on october 19th for our
next episode from 12 until 1 pm eastern
time
uh and please check out our past
recordings on
on marketing for the now at
mftn.vaynerx.com
and we'd love to hear from you so give
us your ideas your thoughts at
marketingforthenow at
vaynerx.com and we will see you soon
thanks